euh il y a également cette vidéo très
forte de la mère de naë qui a réagi à la
remise en liberté du policier accusé
d'avoir tué son fils vous le savez on en
a parlé cette semaine l'auteur du tir
mortel euh est sorti de préson après 4
mois de détention provisoire et
plusieurs demandes de remise en liberté
et la maman de naë est en colère elle
parle d'injustice regardez euh
dites-nous ce que vous en pensez de ça
parce que vous avez vous avez déjà on en
a déjà parlé là cette semaine mais
reditnous regardez le 27 juin 2023 mon
fils unique Naël a été tué par un
policier depuis 4 mois et demi il était
en détention provisoire après quatre
demandes de remise en liberté il est
finalement relâché une véritable
injustice comment la vie de mon fils
peut-elle avoir si peu de valeur quel
message est envoyé un policier tue un
enfant arabou
noir devient millionnaire et sort de
prison retrouve sa famille
tranquillement pour les
fait moi je retrouverai plus jamais mon
fils dimanche 19 novembre venez nombreux
nombreuses pour nous soutenir à 15h sur
la place Nelson modela à nanter justice
pour
Naël alors euh très
émouvant très émouvante la vidéo de de
la merère de Naël euh Jacques Cardo
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous moi je
comprends la douleur de cette femme euh
et je comprends qu'elle ne comprennent
pas euh est-ce que vous vous comprenez
mais je comprends je comprends la
douleur de cette femme mais je comprends
qu'elle ne comprennent pas parce que euh
ce que ce que je voudrais lui dire c'est
que elle sous-entend que la police est
raciste elle sous-entend que la vie d'un
enfant noir ou d'un enfant arabe selon
la police aurait moins de valeur c'est
ce qu'elle c'est ce qu'elle dit dans son
dans son texte moi ça ça me choque non
bah si moi ça me choque ça me choque
parce que les fait ne le montre pas
c'est ce qui s'est passé est très
malheureux je comprends sa douleur mais
je je je pardon mais il y a un moment
donné où bon qu'elle appelle à un
rassemblement qu'elle parle de de
quelque chose de choquant à propos de de
la cagnotte mais il y a deux cognotes
deux cagnotes qui ont été lancées au
même moment ça qu'est-ce que tu veux la
population
je la justice est passée la justice est
passée les décisions sont
passé bon Daniel qui veut réagir c'est
très difficile évidemment d'être contre
ce ce message parce qu'il est émouvant
en revanche c'est totalement
irresponsable parce que quand elle dit
une phrase comme ça ça va vous avez vu
les émeutes ça va rallumer le feu et et
c'est c'est totalement irresponsable de
on va avoir à nouveau des émeutes juste
avec cette phrase là et vous voyez bien
que cette femme la pauvre sa douleur
elle est incommensurable et vraiment il
y a aucun discussion là-dessus mais elle
lit un texte et elle est
instrumentalisé dansor condition mais ça
on va pas évidemment tout le monde
a FEM je suis désolé ça c'est pas un
sujet le vrai sujet c'est que Assad
Traoré était très présente à la
manifestation qui a déclenché les
émeutes ass tré la sœur d'AD Traoré qui
qui a un combat voilà qui a un combat
contre la la police les vavures
policières donc je suis désolé il faut
pas se voiler les faes la face on on se
sert de la douleur de cette MRE pour à
nouveau rallumer le feu parce que c'est
c'est le combat de certain personnes
excuse-moi il faut le dire c'est le
combatre certaines personnes le chaos
LF va rentrer là peut-être j'ai vu les
seuls trucs que j'ai vu là-dessus c'est
c'est c'est des messages de les fill
donc je suis désolé faut pas voilà
maintenant ça ne remet pas en cause la
douleur de cette mère mais on s'en sert
et c'est dégueulasse non déjà tu dis
qu'elle lit un texte moi je suis désolée
cette mère là elle vient de perdre son
enfant elle vient d'apprendre que
l'auteur de des faits a été relâché
forcément elle est elle elle est en
train de dire un texte je pense que
n'importe qui pourrait pas être spontané
et dire les chos de lui-même je pense
que ça on peut pas lui reprocher ensuite
moi je comprends pas parce que quand je
relis la phrase qu'elle a dit un
policier tu tue un enfant arabe ou noir
oui c'est un fait ensuite il devient
millionnaire oui c'est un fait il sort
de prison oui c'est un fait j'ai pas
fini j'ai pas fini si tu peux me laisser
terminer moi je ne retrouverai plus
jamais mon fils oui c'est un fait en
fait on peut pas lui reprocher cette
phrase c'est un fait c'est la réalité
phras
évidich réaganmichel jemichel ou alors
tu as des illères où tu fais semblon de
pas voir quand il dit ça ça c'est
sous-entendu évidemment comme djà que
s'il avait été blanc l'issue n'aurait
pas été la même li entre les lignes fa
pas elle dit elle aurait pu dire quand
la police tu un enfant làelle dit qu' un
enfant noir ou arabe c'est qu'elle
sousentendant elle sousentend la Pol
qu'est-ce que tu as pensé toi bah moi je
trouve que elle elle a un avocat elle un
avocat qui est très très compétent il
aurait pu lui dire quand même lui
expliquer que c'était ce qui s'était
passé tout à fait légal et dans la juste
norme de ce qui se passe dans ce genre
d'affaire il a même été plus longtemps
plus il a été plus longtemps en prison
que si quelqu'un avait fait la même
chose il a fait plus de préventif que
quelqu'un d'autre parce que justement on
n pas on a voulu calmer les émetiers et
calmer a la population on l'envoyer un
message fort en le mettant derrière les
barreaux plus longtemps qu'ilurait par
ton fils devient millionnaireends que
genre j'ai lu ça sur les réseaux genre
le tueur de Naël 4 mois de prison il est
tranquille non c'est 4 mois de préventif
il un procès ou mais c'est toi qui a des
illè Jean-Michel toi qui a des parce que
moi je suis convaincu que si dans cette
voiture c'était un petit blondinet on
aurait réfléchi je su désolé on aurait
réfléchi à deux fois avantant
bes pileil dans le piège tu tombes
pileil dans le piège qu'on vient de
décire Daniel tout à l'heure c'estàd que
le fait tenir ce discours en partant du
présupposé que parce que serait un
enfant noir ou arabe la police aurait
tiré ou aurait un comportement qui
serait différent par rapport à un blond
c'est insupportable je vais te dire
pourquoi mais ils on ils ontigpn ils
sont contrôlés les flics il y a pas un
fait de racisme dans la police qui soit
prouvé aussi de façon aussi évidente
qu'aux États-Unis il y a eu des
événements bien sûr je dis pas que il y
a pas des éléments qui peuvent être
racistes mais je veux dire là tu
sousentendrais oui non mais là tu
sousentendrais ce que çac mais moment
faut arrêter de toujours stigmatiser
mettre tout le monde dans le même panier
je suis pas en train de
direeuxés dis moi je pense que dans la
police en effet il y a une branche qui
est sûement minime mais qui existe
désolé
leô pe Ren on pe pas parler je termine
juste il y a très peu de cas non dis pas
des branch je te laisse
parler BR des des fait une
organisation de que c'est un milieu dans
lequel en effet
leô en a partout il a auss racistes chez
les Africains les as sont r bien s que
oui oui mais les policiers ont une arme
les policiers ont une arme ils ont un
devoir d'exemplarité la police c'est un
métier particulier où c'est
imp ça moins d'impact d'avoir un
boulanger raciste un policier raciste il
y a des moi j'ai grandi à Mantel jolie
je connais bien la banlieu j'ai fait
toutes mes études là-bas et après je
suis partie à Paris j'ai vu moi mes
potes black et rebux qui étaient victime
de dé lit de sale gueule les
arrestations voilà donc après je parle
pas de cette affaire là et je dis pas
que ça êt un Mach je
vais
a blan son Tab par sont
blan tu peux pas tu ne peux pas le nier
non
plus je P cette femme lorsque il lui
arrive ça voilà elle perd son enfant qui
a 17 ans après évidemment je suis pas du
tout d'accord pour dire que c'était un
petit ange loin de là voilàon il a fait
ce qu'il a fait bien sûr mais je
comprends effectivement sa douleur et je
peux comprendre pose cette question
voilà tout simplement on peut se poser
la question benah en fait ouais c'est un
dialogue de Sour en fait du coup moi je
suis quand même assez choqué par ce que
tu as dit Hugo malgré tout parce que tu
on a l'impression queil y a une sorte de
de de de
système de système un peu genre
parallèle dans la police un peu raciste
avec des fes qui se lèvent en gros pour
aller tuer des des noirs ou des
Arabes laiss fin laiss moi je pense que
oui il doit y avoir des délites fess
absolument comme la discrimination à l'
comm des avec des nom qui ont des
consonances plus ou moins on va dire
Arab tout ça oui qui trouvent pas
d'emploi et ça évidemment il faut le
condamner et c'est très grave mais en
disant en disant ça moi je ne dis pas
que les policiers se lèvent le matin en
étant raciste en disant je vais aller
but
des jeis
perséé de fois quand le me est pas pas
sur poli une très
vit souvérou alors vas-y non non mais tu
te souviens il y a eu il y a eu il y a
eu quelques mètres plus loin euh juste
avant il a été on dit pas que ce qu'il a
fait c'est bien c'est ça aussi oui non
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que tu
sous-entends que ser une action d'un
policier et que il est dérapé parce que
parce qu'il a vu que ce serait un noir
ou un arabe et pas un blondinet c'est ce
que tu viens de dire on est d'
caricature mais un peu ce que tu dis
quand même j'ai dit sil était blond on
la question
onuadé non mais on va pas refaire le
détail mais on sait que dans le déroulé
des faits il a eu plusieurs sommations à
avant il aurait pu s'arrêter donc pas en
train de te dire que c'est un petit an
moi je dis pas que c'est un petit sopie
a tout résumé Sophie c'est exactement ça
ce que tu as dit c'est pas parce que on
on on on met en avant le fait que
potentiellement dans un métier qui est
très important dans notre société et où
il y a où il y a un port d'armes où il y
a une responsabilité de protection de la
des civils c'est un métier qui est très
important et ben c'est pas parce que on
dit qu'il y a un problème potentiel dans
une partie de cette population ça veut
dire que on est qu'on est qu'on met
qu'on dit tous les flics tous leslis des
rass fait fa trout Hugo c'est que quand
on reçoit ici par exemple des policiers
ou des syndicats policiers avec avec qui
sont arabes ou qui sont noirs et ben
tous me disent qu'ils reçoivent des
milliards d'insultes en disant vous êtes
des collaburs vous êtes des Arabes de
service donc ça veut bien dire queil y a
un problème ça veut dire que eux ils
disent exactement comme nous comme
Jean-Michel comme Jacques et comme moi
tu vois ils disent pas comme vous ils
disent que par exemple la police n'est
pas raciste et eux on les traite de
raciste parce qu'il sont dans la police
donc tu vois bien qu'il y a un problème
en fait ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'intition oui mais ça veut dire que la
poli on a pas entendu moi ce qui me gêne
dans ce qu'a dit Hugo c'est que on a
l'impression encore une fois d'un
racisme systémique il a pas dit
çaiss encore rien dit donc peux même
plus dire une phrase c'estàd que là il a
quand même dit que effectivement lui a
tiré dessus parce qu'il était noir ou
arabe et s'il était blondiné on lui
aurait pas tiré dessus ça c'est choquant
là Hugo moi je m'insurge contre
ça qu'il y ait non mais qu'il bah
laissez-moi finir qu'il y ait dans la
police des dérapages
bienend mais une organisation dans la
rac
strur branche BR
c'est il y a pas une volonté dans la
police délibérée de tuer des noirs et
des Arabes si on dit ça c'est la
révolution en France c'est impossible de
dire ça moà c'est tout ce que je voulais
dire et je
terminoss mais c'est fa en fa SOP dit
quand tu mais quand tu vis quand tu vis
en banlieu tu te rends bien compte que
quand tu as un look particulier quand tu
as un style
particulier et ben tout tout se dirige
vers toi oui c'est pas juste c'est pas
juste c'est pas tour 2 secondes un
Petitot non mais Hugo il y aurait des
morts tous les jours si la police il
s'amusait à tuer sur les Arabes et les
Noirs toute la journée si il y aura des
morts tous les jours tu peux pas dire
que la police tue systématiquement des
noirs et des Arabes non mais joue pas
sur la sémantique des mot moi je sais
pas parler c'est juste tu as dit voilà
s'il était blond il serait parti moi je
lis autour de ça je me dis que tu penses
que la police tue quand il voit un noir
un Arab et pas quand c'est un blanc
système toujours la lumière sur le même
profil de personne et ça peut être
dangereux pour C personn on va se
retrouver dans un instant les chées pour
la suite de l'émission il y a Miriam
Palomba